fantastic
you're in sports casual I'm in costume
but you work with Jackson lamb yeah
what's he like
it's quite exciting to come back ready
for more in this season of slow horses
yeah coming back was a real choice in
July to see all the old faces it becomes
like it's a family yeah this is Soho but
where's all the prostitutes of the
junkies so ashamed shut up Mike Marcus
how would you characterize lamb and
River's relationship throughout the
course of the show it's sort of tough
love with with River because I see
potential right so what do I do then
piss off to the job center for all our
care
the way he is with everybody it's not
malicious it's not nasty I've met people
like that and so have you that when they
find someone they think is very good
they're particularly hard on them and
they write they write they yeah well I
mean where I come from if you take the
pests that much out of someone that is a
mark of respect absolutely genuine
affection is the worst thing you can do
to another human being
if you uncovered the trail that quickly
it couldn't have been that well hidden
thanks
I've learned a ridiculous amount from
you you have a ridiculous amount one of
my favorite things was as an actor
watching you work the scene out and get
halfway through and go now that doesn't
work and not lose the head be like I'll
find it at some point yeah then people
should sell tickets to that kind of
stuff
I'm very impressed
by how confident you are even if I know
it all might be it's bollocks an act you
appear to be
confident and relaxed anyway he's
definitely onto me are you sure yeah you
don't want to get closer
this season is in part A Revenge story
yeah yeah and it's going to work right
gangbusters although we shouldn't give
too much away
he was following someone when he died
maybe he saw someone that he shouldn't
have why a slow house been dragged into
this we're nobody's
[Music]